okay let's begin with some breaking news
out of lebanon the caretaker prime
minister is being charged over the
beirut
port explosion which devastated the city
hassan diab and three former ministers
are accused of negligence about 200
people were killed in the august the
fourth disaster
with thousands injured and many more
left homeless
it was caused by a huge stockpile of
highly explosive ammonium nitrate
which had been improperly stored at the
port for six years
okay let's get more from zeno holder in
beirut xena just bring us up to date
with what we know about this so far
well like you mentioned the significant
breakthrough for the first time in this
investigation
politicians have been charged
previously it was mid-level low-level
employees at the port
and custom authorities so now the judge
is saying that he has enough evidence to
at least
initiate proceedings against the
caretaker prime minister hassan dieb
as well as a number of former ministers
he believes that they had a role that
they were negligent
and now we are getting reaction from the
caretaker prime minister hassan dieb
he is saying that he is surprised
that he is being targeted he's saying
that his conscience is clear
and he is questioning really the leading
judge
sawan saying that you know accusing him
of violating the constitution and
bypassing parliament saying it's
parliament's really a jurisdiction to
question
ministers there has been a debate for
some time now
on which authority in lebanon has the
right uh our jurisdiction
uh to question and investigate the
politicians
last week or 10 days ago the judge
asked parliament to investigate
ministers parliament refused to do that
the speaker of parliament said that
first you have to issue
an indictment so many will believe that
maybe the different branches of
government
are trying to buy time or at least
trying to show the lebanese public that
they are doing something
uh because they have come under a lot of
criticism for the slow
moving investigation many human rights
groups really have criticized it for
lacking credibility and lacking
transparency
and zeno we saw in the aftermath of that
explosion but also
in the run-up to it as well furious
demonstrations in the streets of beirut
particularly over allegations of
corruption amongst the government
is there any indication although as we
know this is a breaking story but is
there any early indication that this
might go some way
to try to allay the anger that the
people have felt about this
yes a lot of public anger been speaking
uh
to people they're saying well yes this
is a step forward
but it's definitely not enough and
there's another thing
people have lost faith in the
authorities even in the judiciary which
many have accused of being
politicized they really believe that
this could be part of a game some will
say why are you pointing the finger at
dieb he took office just
a few months uh before the the the
explosion a little-known figure who's
not backed by any political party who
had no influence at the port
and that they should go after quote
unquote but people are calling the big
players the different political parties
all of them had representatives at that
port all of them had influence at that
point
and that port you know there has been a
lot of corruption allegations
but there are others who believe that
jeb didn't do his job
because in july security officials
put a report on his table on his table
and on the president's table
saying that there's thousands of tons of
ammonium nitrate that they report and
they pose a security risk
and neither him nor the president did
anything about it in fact he was even
scheduled died was scheduled to visit
the port before that explosion to visit
that warehouse
and he did it and he acknowledged that
and he said that he postponed the visit
because
um he was receiving conflicting reports
uh so some will tell you that this is a
significant step forward
others will say that he could you know
jeb could be a scapegoat
and others could say that they're just
buying time because it really boils down
to
many really not having faith in the
political class that has been governing
this country for decades
and many believe that they are
responsible for this explosion because
of the negligence and corruption
and not only at the port but in in other
state institutions
as well xenocardia in beirut bringing us
up to date with the breaking news out of
lebanon the caretaker prime minister and
three former ministers
have been charged in connection with the
beirut port explosion xena thank you
very much indeed